меметика міс тачку-то куховарку і ж
прикрасьте витягнуті давидова на поставила
не для біженців зони ато
квітки збер не буду, але китани орхідні
обладнання
літні надходять і зніме шини на
початку жовта тут хоч трохи
а б біженці від часу теплий портулак
а до нового уроку ці пляшечки
опалева і тебе за допомогою
електроенергії
біля замкнутих кімнат буде до 20 градусів
тепла
я поведу молодий ворушив федеральному
міністерстві економічно гості грубить на
твоє розвідування місця очко за десять
маленьких кластерах а шкіра на 32 особи
Петро i великий та йому жити в син це сяо
до червона по 56 сіл сіл видно з
планами братові лак тут знай дуть був з
купе у тисячі людей кожен почесний
консул не меншу харкові
Тетяна Гавриш вона розроблена таким чином
чином все можна викласти та раді на топ
такий собі кластер та й спальня кухня
санітарні приміщення факту, що там може
проживати до 45 осип а їдеш вал річці
приміщення ці розруха ван і на
транзитних віталів топ то там їдуть я 2
ревну
ліжка ти можеш люди може прорости 23
днів
загальна vortice будівник рубає
близько 620 тисяч євро про диких 220 000 в
дружина дала негайно гори що моя
профінанс уват та українська сторона
роботи підібгалися а на початку жовта не
відриваючи підключення до електромаш
у зручну каналізації ним набряки технікою
спина з українською та бунтує втомлюється
доволи швидко про гірші від аромати такі
блага цивілізації ви стала
краще рівна поставив вони вже така
записалася в дівочі більше людей, а не
шуми стати ним ці коміс.
у приймай управління соціального за
хасту
телефонна мавка я по мишка не виділять і
мульти producing соціально-незахищеним
таким його німецької сторони ми
черга ми за цим родом будемо
розглядати і потребу обожнювання жити і
us їхніх пляшечках багата бітних рубін
рубін та й січень
види особливі в де ти самотній їх
моторизований del самотніх матерів
про dance територіальних центрів хорькова
комп'ютера не класи тему соціального
закладу залито слухати жезлом для
біженців зони ато
1 ст їхніх батьків Володимир і Валентино
чаркаша не новою вже вранці вловити
німецького уряду
сертифікат на оре ширшова посилаючи їх я
данина
народилося а равлик у харкові з
патологія але ніяк звичайно там
пляшечка завись але гарніша
парять душ туалет з дати іншу там краєчки
попрад і
us open боку макбука а в тему літньому
таборі room hkd також машкович близько
сотні вигаданих переселенців із донбасу
і духи не моя впала не гривні до тамбуру
разом за волонтером і смаглявою зеброю ти
вантажник вище на встановлення котла
батарей алина пити води немає руб коштив
на вас то чаю наталі з донецька
за своїми двома дітьми і дідусь м навіть
жартувала відрив від і красиво мого
проживання не обіцяє йому таборі вона
точно знає з чон і стежкою кінематика
міс.
я не мати-одиначка тобто я не п'яна
мати та 1 очка на інвалід я реально
розумію, що ми їм не підходи маза
критеріями для посилання від їхньої пляшечки
там біля мису диму і чика йому на відома
тшуву якщо ми
обігрівати кроком його гривками
наталі за вище сил то бурі на витік сич
він виявите впав і не і ти їм нікуди обидва
готує народи на берлінських я до наявності
16 осип у животі і цада переїзду
меметика міс.
нині тебе вали до родини юрособи орендовані
легким над не квартирою та rhino то
Віталій здається, щоб то і шляхи сни то
синематики пляшечках а ви і до можу
більше біженців змогли попрацювати там
всю зиму про тепло
породи на бєлінську з нетерпінням така
завершення будемо дитинства заданому
німецькому уряду на заради місця очок
цього на 70 сотки
роботи прокидаються шведку теж прибрали та
ухар qfp думки сім'ї біженців зможе
за свій до містечка як це планово на до
нового уроку